okay so getting into really the the last
story as part of Jason Aaron's run on
the Incredible Hulk we pick up with a
story called United now you're not it's
kind of interesting because it's not
really how we would expect an Incredible
Hulk story to be right like most people
read Incredible Hulk because I just want
to see him smash stuff but with the
Incredible Hulk what's so interesting is
the character like the character of
Bruce Banner the character of the Hulk
and self you know those aspects I think
are what makes the characters so
intriguing because it's like how they
relate to one another and so what we end
up doing here is in the last video we
had we had really left off with the idea
that the Incredible Hulk had just woken
up with you know haven't been strapped
to a chair with Bruce Banner giving him
a message and so what happens is we sort
of wrap back around to the beginning of
the story from Bruce banners perspective
again the idea that he had basically
been separated that he had been split
away from the Incredible Hulk
into a wholly new being but the issue
with this and the struggle with this is
that in his mind he doesn't remember a
lot of what happened he's just kind of
remembering on his moments of being
psychotic in the sense that in his mind
he remembers a little bit about trying
to recreate a gamma bomb trying to re
merger the Incredible Hulk
and of course dying but at that point
that was when he had basically reemerged
back with the Incredible Hulk again but
didn't realize it and so all Bruce
Banner knew was darkness and in his mind
he thought he was actually dead which is
kind of cool because it gives us a
little bit of insight into how people
perceive a concept of death just total
blackness or maybe it's a paradise or
something along those lines but this is
when Bruce Banner began to realize that
he and the Hulk had basically combined
back into one again when he woke up next
to Betty Ross in her Red Hulk form now
following this Bruce began to set his
plans into motion this is actually kind
of a cool moment hear what Bruce video
was cash
he needed money he needed the ability to
buy the kind of services that were
necessary in order to begin setting his
plan in motion as the what are you done
is basically this gone to a casino and
just played roulette I mean that's kind
of weird he just plays roulette and then
just wins you know wins a ton of cash
and then turns around and uses that to
begin the process of kind of building up
his empire now the funny thing about
this is that he uses the name Joe fix-it
and a buddy of mine Raymond that I
haven't talked to Raymond for a long
time but a buddy of mine Raymond hit me
up on Facebook and asked me about geo
fiction he's like what can you tell me
about the character of Joe fix-it so
here's the deal when the Incredible Hulk
was first introduced in Marvel Comics he
was great I mean that's no secret at
this point but he was great the issue is
that it only lasted for about six issues
because of the fact that they couldn't
keep the gray scheme going it was just
too difficult with printing presses as
existed at the time and so because of
that they made him green now great hulk
was brought back but the green version
of The Incredible Hulk was intrinsic to
his character is B Incredible Hulk
everybody thought of as they couldn't
just suddenly make him gray with no real
explanation as to what was going on I
said what they did is they took the
great concept and made it a wholly
different version of the Hulk and
somebody just called him Joe fix it and
so Joe fix it was just this version of
the Hulk that lived in Las Vegas and was
really more of a mobster than anything
else kind of like a hired hand
bouncer sort of situation but again we
covered a lot of that stuff when we did
Greg patch run from Planet Hulk going up
until we started this run but what this
does it's basically kind of fast
forwards by about a week in the sense
that once you began the process of
getting all this money together once he
got his resources together did it
basically picked up with the Incredible
Hulk as we saw here but him just kind of
waking up in different places and so on
and so forth and so a really cool moment
comes when you know following the events
of the Hulk versus of you know the thing
in Wolverine and the Hulk turns back
into Bruce Banner again there's a really
cool moment in the sense where a banner
hit basically you know contacted a
doctor who's kind of worked for hire a
lot of discretions maintained where the
identities of the people aren't really
taken into account but man it was picked
up by these guys and was basically
worked on restored to help that kind of
thing but when the doctor goes to leave
it's almost this existential crisis
right like banner doesn't know who he is
he doesn't know what he's about not
innocence that he lost his memory I mean
he has his memory and everything it's
just kids know where he's going in the
world you know like what's this all
leading to you know Who am I really on a
fundamental level and it's really kind
of cool because the whole aspect of the
whole personality kind of throws that
into fray and that's been the whole
basis behind his character right like
the whole explanation of him losing his
mind going insane based on the fact that
he and The Incredible Hulk had been
split was designed to ask the question
who is banner without the whole what is
he really is the Hulk a crutch
more so than an actual aspect of his
personality the Incredible Hulk is the
mean by which Banner can just kind of
let loose it's kind of cut loose and let
things unfold or is he really just kind
of a prisoner in his own mind he just
can't escape be Incredible Hulk and
every once in a while he's just kind of
held captive when the Incredible Hulk
persona is dominant it acts a lot of
these really really cool questions about
the relationship between Banner and the
Hulk proper now for us at this point we
pick up with banner kind of tracking
down Doctor Doom and basically asking
the question that's really at the root
of all this why did dr. doom help banner
in the first place but this is kind of
funny because when I initially went over
the the beginning of the story we really
didn't
focus on dr. doone too much in terms of
chronology because I wanted to wait
until this moment to flesh that out but
that moment with dr. doom when he had
basically worked on the Incredible Hulk
when he had split Hulk and Banner into
two different people this took place
during the fall out of Hickman's
fantastic for the future foundation and
all that stuff the way to future
foundation story ended dr. doom was
basically among the remnants of the
council of reeds with all those versions
of himself that have been taken prisoner
by the council of reeds and have been
lobotomized so that's one of the reasons
why and that story was like doom doom
you know and he looks at the look at us
was the viewer he looks at the reader
and says I can build here because it was
basically him being away from the main
Marvel Universe that's why there's all
these doom bots here because these doom
bots are kind of just waiting on Doctor
Doom to come back but they also begin to
build a little bit of sentience and
we'll talk about that here in a second
but the idea is that again this all
basically circles back to the ending of
the last video when Hulk wakes up to
this broadcast from Bruce Banner and
this is crazy because Bruce Banner looks
at the Hulk and says look man we've been
fighting for ever like ever since we've
been in existence ever since you first
manifested we've been fighting each
other you've been fighting for dominance
I've been fighting for dominance we end
up having to share the same body for
once even if it's only just to go after
Doctor Doom and to get the answer to the
question of why you helped us and what
his ulterior motive is for once let's
just work together like let's just come
together and let's just defeat Doctor
Doom let's just beat him this one ton
and that's what they do what we get here
is this kind of perfect version of Bruce
Banner in the Incredible Hulk working in
unison now this is not the first time
this has happened it's happened before
there's been stories where the
Incredible Hulk had the intelligence of
Bruce Banner you know where Bruce Banner
kind of allowed that aspect of his body
to be used by the Incredible Hulk
there's been times where Bruce Banner
has had the strength of the Incredible
Hulk we saw that in old man Logan
but we've almost never seen an instance
where the two of them have worked in
perfect unison before what their motives
were so perfectly lined up that they
basically became a singular cohesive
being and so this is almost an
indication of what Bruce Banner should
have been you know when he was first
blasted by the gamma bomb this is almost
an indication of what he should have
turned out as how he should have
appeared now of course this coincides
with the arrival of you know I guess the
return of Amanda Von Doom and the mad
squad and so on and so forth again the
whole reason for that is because of the
fact that they were assigned to
originally assigned to track down Bruce
Banner because of the fact that Banner
had basically re-emerged or I guess
merged back again with the Incredible
Hulk and Banner has been cited in
different
around the world they kind of brought
them back together again just because of
the fact that you know from the
perspective of Amanda Von Doom who lied
about killing banner in the first place
and so on and so forth but picking up
with these doombots what we end up
finding out is that again because of the
fact that it was the original Doctor
Doom who split Bruce Banner in the
Incredible Hulk who has since you know
taken off as part of a part of the
Future Foundation and it's simply these
doombots left to carry out his work the
doombots were always kind of this
interesting situation in the Fantastic
Four mythos the doombots were this idea
that was sort of tour toured around with
and different riders depicted them
different ways on the whole the idea of
a Doombot is that the person talking to
it will never know that it's not Doctor
Doom it's designed to function and be
the same as Doctor Doom in almost every
former fashion but this was really kind
of like focused on more so by Ed
Brubaker during the story the books of
doom than it ever was and any other
story is probably the greatest story
fleshing out the nature of doom busts in
the sense the stories designed to give
us like this full origin of Doctor Doom
but it's not until the end of the story
that we find out that is being told by a
Doombot now of course again this was
designed to just kind of you know show
us how far the doombots go what their
programming is how they're designed to
be autonomous ideally the doombots are
there so that they can just carry out
the whims and wants of Doctor Doom and
he never really has to do anything but
that's also a kind of a funny situation
here is because when Doctor Doom appears
to people you never know if it's really
him or if it's a Doombot that's the
purpose of the doombots they're like
life model decoys for Doctor Doom but
they're specific to him now of course
because of the fact that Doctor Doom
himself is actually off the world as
part of the Future Foundation the
doombots
are curing at his programs are carrying
out his goal his overarching plan and
this is when we learn what his plan is
it's planning submission we follow up
with what Bruce Banner did you know the
Bruce Banner after being separated from
the Incredible Hulk
Banner began the process of just
creating these gamma-irradiated animals
you know lions and tigers and bears oh
I'm sorry I had to you know but he
started creating these irradiated
animals on this island doom took that
concept and continued it on now again
this also coincides with the idea of the
mad squad kind of coming together and
then working alongside the Incredible
Hulk but it's also the idea that they
captured one of their own doom bots and
so at this point it is kind of breaking
it down and trying to figure out
everything that it knows and learning to
understand what it is that it's about
and so what this does is it also reveals
to us that the doom bots still consider
Bruce Banner and the Incredible Hulk
- the illegitimate threat and some
because of the fact that anybody who
speaks to a Doombot doesn't really know
that it's not dr. doom they use this to
their advantage in the sense that they
actually approach a company called brain
damage incorporated and this company
basically exists for the purpose of just
kind of going through infiltrating
people's minds and then wreaking all
kinds of havoc now again they are one of
a multitude of groups that serve this
purpose and that's why I like little
inclusions about this you know in this
comic and in other comics that we see
throughout Marvel Comics is because even
if they only appear once we end up
seeing this sort of bolstering in terms
of these different landscapes and the
different groups of play roles and so on
and so forth you know for example back
in the 1970s 1967 I think it was I think
was x-men number 28 there was a group
that was introduced called factor 3 they
were just a group of people that were
led by a guy named mutant master and we
just want to take over the world but
it's these different organizations and
different groups that exist throughout
Marvel Comics that serve all different
manner of purposes some of which have
their own motivations in mind for
example you know damage control
incorporated damage control incorporated
was the legitimate company they just
went through and cleaned up cities after
superhero conflicts you know it wasn't
until during the events of civil war
that we learned that they were basically
instigating conflicts for the purpose of
maintaining their own government
contract so again it was really kind of
kind of a cool idea in a cool situation
towards all these different groups and
so on but of course this leads to the
mad squad basically invading Latveria or
invading the base of these doombots and
facing off against them but the other
half of this is we actually get a little
bit a little bit of a look on the inside
of Bruce banners mind now in truth this
is the mindscape there is no physical
structure when it comes to the interior
of Bruce banners mind but you know in
this instance it's really just goose and
Aaron and company giving us the best
look that we can get in the context but
also adding a little bit of humor to it
the simple they've actually got like
physical controls the hulk hits a smash
button whenever he wants to start
tearing stuff up if these funny little
moments you know that make make these
stories so cool and make them so
interesting but the other half of this
is that we end up finding out that
rain-damaged Incorporated had basically
unleashed a guy called the vegetable and
the reason why they call them that is
because he's a really powerful telepath
who's stuck in a vegetative state but
he's able to basically enter the minds
of other people and then in turn begin
attacking them now this kind of
stretches the limits of credulity to a
little bit it actually kind of asked us
a few different questions because one of
the most notable aspects of the
Incredible Hulk is that he has been
overcome by different telepaths
but he's also got some kind of telepath
shilling and it's really one of these
ideas worse just whatever the writer
calls forward any particular point in
time when the whole set is absolute
strongest it's almost impossible for a
telepath to take him out when the hoax
in a really calm state or when he's
taken by surprise a telepath can enter
his mind so again it's really one of
these situations where it depends on
what level he's at you know what mine
said he's in at that particular point in
time whether he's expecting telepathic
attack or not it's just different ways
to kind of kind of deal with it I mean
with this story it's really the idea of
Jason Aaron kind of going back to the
roots of the Incredible Hulk and saying
if there is a telepath out there strong
enough they will be able to enter the
mind to the Incredible Hulk and they
will be able to take him down again this
isn't the first time we've seen that
that was the whole big deal with Jean
Grey you know during the onslaught saga
she entered the mind of the Incredible
Hulk she suppressed the Bruce Banner
personality Bruce Banner attacked
onslaught and he was the only person
that was able to punch a hole in the
armor of onslaught allowing you know the
heroes to jump in and then kick off the
heroes reborn landscape but the fact
remains here whose feet are facing off
against the vegetable this is actually a
really cool moment because with the
vegetables kind of you know just
unleashing this psychic attack on Bruce
Banner Bruce banners response is I
fought everything and I've seen and done
everything I fought men I thought gods
I fought mutants I seen and done it all
but the most terrifying thing that I
could ever endure is my own mind and the
cool thing about this is that like arms
actually reach out and grab this
vegetable and of course Bruce Banner
begins fighting back against a vegetable
on it you know with the help of these
arms but what just does is it hits home
at the idea that these are all basically
just arms that belong to different
versions of the Hulk or even other
personalities the Bruce Banner has you
know for example Joe fix it you know his
arms are available in there there's
savage Hulk presumably or maybe some
other iteration of the Incredible Hulk
just these different arms that
physically manifest themselves in
different ways and they really just kind
of represent all the psychotic states of
Bruce banners mind presumably all the
personalities that he has stuck in his
head now this does not mean that Bruce
Banner is like Legion you know and even
then this could just be the physical
manifestation of his internal mind and
the sense he's using his mind to work
against the vegetable it could be any
number of things that we can interpret
in any number of different ways but at
the end of the day it's really Bruce
Banner just kind of fighting back
against the vegetable using its own
abilities and then just overcoming the
vegetable accordingly but again because
of the fact that your spanner kind of
takes back over control of the situation
allows the Incredible Hulk to face off
against the vegetable in his own
again you know another example of these
two guys from working in tandem working
together and it shows us that yeah this
may not be the most powerful version of
the whole this is not the strongest
version of the halters ever been but in
a lot of ways they're actually better
where breaker hulk was was really one of
the strongest versions of the whole but
with regards to the two of them working
together it's the intelligence of Reese
banner with the formidable strength of
the Incredible Hulk that's limitless
working in tandem and that allows them
to overcome virtually any situation in
this instance alongside that squad
they're able to subdue both the
vegetable inside the mind of Bruce
Banner at the hands of the Hulk as well
as the doombots by Bruce Banner himself
so again you know because the fact that
Banner had developed the secure and
chose not to use it on the Incredible
Hulk he in turn uses it on all the
different monsters that have been
treated you know then basically
manipulated or at least the monsters and
people who have been manipulated by dr.
doom and banner himself returning them
back to their normal state so again it
wraps back around to the beginning of
the story it starts to tie up all these
different loose ends and again you know
like some monkey throws poop in banners
face or an eternity Incredible Hulk and
presumably goes after the monkey kind of
ending on a little bit of a of a comedic
no but this is again just kind of a
self-contained story and that was really
the idea with the Incredible Hulk coming
after Greg patch run because Greg patch
run was so extensive because it predates
Planet Hulk running through Planet Hulk
going through World War Hulk followed
the hooks world war hoax because of the
fact you can't do all those different
things
it was this massively expansive run of
his character it was so incredibly huge
and so the idea was not to repeat that
the idea was just hand the Incredible
Hulk over to some writers and see what
they could do see what kind of stories
they could craft you know what kind of
stories they could tell
that's what was really just kind of like
a series of small self-contained
adventures that didn't really last
anything more than you know 20 issues
apiece or something like that so anyway
if you guys are new here to come and
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the robb poor
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later please
[Music]
and